[Musica]
Ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata oggi partiamo
col botto siamo in compagnia di Nicole
Rossi barbascura e Antonino Spadaccino
raga
è noioso
ok Siamo qui in compagnia di
Rush barbascura Antonino Ragazzi grazie
mille Io vi ho preparato una piccola
tisanina al volo
ubriacare no no no no no no non è
assicurato che non c'è altro
ragionamento
partiamo via Jingle
[Musica]
Allora noi abbiamo chiesto a tutti
quanti i nostri ascoltatori Ok di
condividere con noi degli audio legati a
delle esperienze terribili avute in
viaggio perché effettivamente noi tre
siamo legati è un'esperienza comune
Antonino tu purtroppo no che cazzo
c'entri io mi faccio i viaggi mentali
Bravissimo Io non l'ho vinto sono
arrivato tipo alla sesta puntata io per
tanto così non l'ho vinto o per tanto io
ho vinto Comunque noi siamo state
Genuine E questa cosa ci ha premiate
senti Allora una volta per missitalia
io ho vinto un talent a 21 anni non ci
provavo Guarda No ma tu hai solo vinto
una laurea in vincere cose per esempio
tu adesso hai vinto dal cuore Sì che
vuoi sapere mi stavi sul cazzo vuoi che
vincete sempre bravo bravo bravo
allora
perché prima sono stata perdente Adesso
voglio prendermi la mia rivincita Io ho
lavorato per 15 anni in tabaccheria di
famiglia e davo i numeri cioè le
vecchiette venivano raccontano Certo
certo lo vedo bene i numeri mica figo
Paolo Limiti
[Applauso]
il tuo sogno un sogno che hai fatto Ah
chi se li ricorda Ma dai ma io non li so
a memoria i numeri Però come li davi
questi numeri in base a un libro che
si chiama quindi la vecchina del caso
velina mi raccontava tutta la cosa ha
sognato la notte cosa ha fatto tu
spogliati spogliato
i numeri e la gente vinceva è capitato
ascoltiamo un audio con la morte nel
cuore breve storia tra parentesi triste
di viaggio seconda vacanza con i miei
fidanzato Budapest scopro che mi tradiva
molto probabilmente con una prostituta
Budapest a Medjugorje Io voglio capire
la dinamica loro vanno insieme via
caputa però Ricominciamo da fare
colazione secondo e lui riesce bene e
lei dice ho un sospettino È così che ha
data lui torna che sa tipo di capito
Chanel numero 5
Dove sei stato per due giorni
no io sono andata col mio ragazzo
proprio in strip club è un video che mi
ha fatto lui mentre metto dei soldi nel
tanga passiamo così simpatico Se volete
farlo fatelo insieme
di Londra Direzione Harry Potter Studios
un certo punto Sale questo tizio tutto
trasandato palesemente fatto in mano
aveva un cartone ripiegato su se stesso
a un certo punto a suo tizio gli cade
una bustina di polverina bianca allora
lui si affretta a cercare di raccogliere
questa polverina nel frattempo ho
lasciato per terra al cartone Bianco a
un certo punto si sente un rumore tipo
un verso di cornacchia No un gracchiare
così ci giriamo e vediamo che c'è una
specie di gabbiano un cielo bianco
abbastanza grosso che usciva da questo
cartone Allora il tizio si ha fretta
cercando di recuperare questo uccello In
qualche modo ci riesce e alla fermata
dopo scende tutto tranquillo come se non
fosse successo niente col suo Povero
gabbiano
hai perduto la tua bamba Esatto sì
quelli sono i famosi uccelli spaccini
vero Vabbè squisiscono
per strada e digli io mi dai un chilo
d'erba Hai presente gli uccelli
è la base cioè questi mancano i miei
viaggi mentali c'è strano
A parte che sono tutti drogati questo è
testato ma poi sono anche presenti
la malavita cioè voglio dire prima di
prendere tutto il giro degli uccelli
cagoni delle città perché prima parte
arriva ad altri uccelli no poi sono
arrivati loro hanno dovuto fare mazzate
c'è stata la guerra urbana tra le tra le
band E poi alla fine la guerra dei Roses
chiedono
tutto sto giro di affari incredibile
continuiamo un attimo di Truman Show
Qual è quella vera di camera
Che vuol dire qual è quella vera di
camera Mamma mia
c'è un gabbiano che ti sta riprendendo
Che vuol dire che vuol dire quella
centrale perché c'ha il computer il
monitor no che vuol dire e gli altri
cosa pensi che siano che cazzo ne so io
vi bene Faccio la youtubers cioè non lo
so non l'ho mai fatto tutte vere tu vuoi
sapere quella che sta su di te la tua
proprio quella la tua personale più
delle volte Enrico e a volte Ciao
dipende da loro uno o l'altro Però
tranquilla con tutte le cose flirtare Ok
andiamo avanti andiamo avanti con un
altro audio Dai facciamo un refill a sto
punto vedo ammazzati Scusate non ho
capito che fosse così aggressivi Ciao
Allora ne ho una fresca fresca
praticamente scorta settimana era Praga
poco prima di partire mi faccio i buchi
all'orecchio premessa prendo dei vaso
dilatatori Vabbè per una roba e quindi
il mio sangue è molto fluido e Niente il
terzo giorno è ancora Praga mi sveglio
qualche goccia di sangue Va beh Niente
avevo paura di discattare Infatti
piangevo dicendo il mio ragazzo non
voglio morire adesso se ci penso io mi
sono cagata sotto
allego foto se non ti fa schifo al
sangue
Shining cioè
Apri l'ascensore vedi questo non so
orecchi questo bello no mi dici
ora Raccontaci la giusta che è successo
in quella stanza Eh vabbè sul cuscino
ragazzi
i cuscini per far vedere tutto rose mi
piace a questo punto tiriamo fuori
qualche bigliettino sono domande Random
Ok Antonino certo devo girarli sono
pericolosi
dipende i bigliettini dei battesimi si
dice il peccato ma non il peccatore
un aneddoto legato al si dice il peccato
ma non il peccatore Hai qualcuno che non
puoi dire chi Ma che ha fatto qualcosa
Oddio ce l'hai devi succhiare meglio
prendi un bigliettino e gioca uhm uhm
vuoi giocare così scusa Aspetta vediamo
se la fortuna vuole assisterti
una cosa che hai detto in passato devi
succhiare meglio
scherzare
vicini di casa Oddio vicini di casa
ragazzi no ecco sono l'unico che
apprezza quando i vicini di casa fanno
sesso Allora hai presente quando dicono
che parli vicini di casa rumorosi che
fanno sesso invece trovo che quando i
tuoi vicini di casa fanno sesso vivi
all'interno di un condominio più sano
prima i miei vicini di casa Erano i miei
genitori Guglielmo perché vivevo con
loro non la trovo una cosa Sandra
quest'anno
io avevo dei vicini piuttosto plateale
dopo un po'
meno Io direi una cosa ci vediamo un
attimo di pausa e facciamo un giochetto
insieme per cui io ti chiederei di
prendere un bigliettino verde saremo due
squadre due contro due ora tu pescherai
il tuo compagno di squadra
automaticamente gli altri due sono in
coppia
Questa è un Meme nudo il prossimo
eliminato è
Antonino
Questo qui è un omaggio a terra Ok
nel senso che
tu fai musica Sì Certamente si
Complimenti facciamo un momento di
sponsor No perché se è appena uscito
stai uscendo col tuo ultimo singolo è
uscito il 13 gennaio il 13 gennaio fai
cagare a fare le prove
sono cose sincere tu sei qui per parlare
il tuo libro o sei qui per parlare con
queste persone non lo so che cosa
vogliamo fare
conduttore Come è nata l'esigenza di
raccontare questo brano Giovanni Caccamo
ha scritto questo brano prezioso per me
ho pensato di utilizzarlo come primo
passo per ritornare a cantare inediti
una canzone italiana dove canzone
italiana Insomma non ce ne sono più un
po' questa esigenza del bel canto
italiano mentre invece nel tuo caso io
so che sei uscita con aria no ok il tuo
secondo e terzo libro
e comunque Allora se l'è portato No
seriamente intanto ci tengo a dire che
questo libro l'ho scritto io e non è una
cosa scontata
Ma tu sei in tour sei Comunque ho citato
la sua canzone Quindi se dopo averla
ascoltata vi piace potete leggerla qui
sto mentendo perché per fare
scomodimento spaziale
capito l'arte purtroppo non accetta il
web L'arte è qualcosa di più intimo non
ne posso parlare qui c'è anche una foto
nudo
tipo fluido eh Compratelo Allora io ho
messo tutta la merda che c'è sul web
cioè l'ipocrisia di una non voglio non
voglio spoilerarvi il tema però ho
trovato un personaggio che
rappresentasse nella vita reale tutto
quello che vediamo sul web mi seguono
si parla di queste tematiche molto
complesse
anche nella vita
[Applauso]
Oddio Che cos'è questa è la mia prima
copia è da Nicole per Nicole Ma oggi
visto che voglio vendere la voglio
regalare a te la prima copia è Guarda è
Sottolineata con le presentazioni cosa
stanno Antonino Ma il tuo cellulare non
volevi regalarlo a Google no è evidente
Nicole Nicole non ci sono almeno 20 20
copie Insomma so che per te è molto
importante aspetta Queste sono le
lacrime perché te ne stai separando io
se nel caso c'ho una pila di piatti da
lavare
se volete c'è qualcuno è quello eh eh Tu
sei turni col tuo spettacolo possiamo
dirlo Sì però fa schifo raga' un colpo
scherzo
Non è vero Io non sono andata a vedere
ragazzi
Ne hai parlato all'interno di questo
libro tu lo sai che io ho curato le
musiche del tuo spettacolo infatti non
ci sono musiche però ti ringrazio
basta basta
Allora cosa c'era in questo Ragazzi
voglio dire che d'ora in poi voglio fare
solo sponsorizzate così che se ne
sognano in TV Vabbè ragazzi è arrivato
il momento di giocare
[Musica]
Senti se parliamo
ok Look at me eh
hai scambiato
come cazzo io Shakira c'è l'IKEA
le curve delle galline cortecce
sciocchezze
no perfetto hai scambiato hai scambiato
con un Rolex con una Ferrari una
una balbettante
ma triste un po' moggio Moggio uno
balbettante barboccio una bomba di
babbuini
Oh balbettante bambocciona Brava
balmetta il Supermoto una balbettante e
bambocciona di babbuininda banda banda
basta raga
con la mossa del giaguaro
la musica Ragazzi grazie grazie
a pallettoni Allora devo cambiarci loro
stanno loro stanno stretti
loro stanno stretti sotto i
lettiera Infatti
smettila eh
Sicuro
Tim Burton Tim Burton
sposa cadavere
Che cos'è la sposa cadavere fantastico
con me devo leggere il suo libro prima
vai vai metti è ripartito
da bambina da bambini ami ami le Winx se
tu lo vuoi tu lo sarai una di noi le
Winx
crescendo da bambino Winx da grande
quando scegli le Trix in centro ci
vediamo in centro no un punto ci siamo
ci siamo dai
Hai un robot
aiuto
me l'hanno Leuca Miranda e hanno messo
il nome scientifico
Ok chi fa molta avete messo il nome
scientifico del Panda Gigante va bene
Hai un robot da aiuto i Modà zio se è
scampi e liberi arriverà il sapore più
hai ahi ahi l'uro l'uno l'uno coda poda
poda pomoda da da ai loro Podda hai un
po'da Ma alla fine pota la fina e Poveri
all'inizio
loro aiuto
Non lo indicare non dobbiamo fare a
Torino sta così dietro No ho fatto così
magnà penna mela Pinna bella me la
mangio questa mela bene mela
Ahia ahia se fai così tu piano piano ma
che come cazzo lo mangi il pene tu cioè
che cazzo fai Che cosa fai
mordiglia piglia Leggilo
ai loro poda da piccola Ami le Winx da
grande Ami le Trix hai uno Bob
sono io Bastardi infami adesso adesso ci
sei mi senti vai come ci sei mi senti
vai vuol dire che sente quel quella
incredibile quelli inverosimile
Incredibile Incredibile
quell'incredibile somiglianza topi
incazza Ah quell'incredibile top in
cazzo Ma che cazzo è il top in casa
somiglianza dominanza somiglianza
somiglianza somiglianza stai dicendo
dominanza somiglia
somiglianza
domiciliare danza tra Guglielmo e
barbascura e barbascura oh oh oh
ok E adesso che fai Ahia adesso che fai
Vai silenzio la la foresta Foresta dei
Fed te D La foresta dei pugnali pugnale
Scusatemi
la foresta La foresta dei pugnali
pugnale pugnali volanti La foresta dei
pugnali volanti
i vincitori perdono i vincitori perdono
i perdenti vincolo E adesso che fai
adesso bisogna dare comunque Comunque io
ero qui solo per promozionare il mio
pezzo Ora posso anche andarmene Grazie
Facciamo così barbascuram Prendimi un
bigliettino Rosa quella volta in cui hai
dimenticato che quella volta in cui ho
dimenticato che non puoi lasciare roba
in custodite in aeroporto era il periodo
di attentati a Nizza che all'epoca stavo
facendo il dottorato e mi stavo
trasferendo avevo un botto di roba era
il periodo in cui non avevo una lira e
quindi prendere l'aereo per me era
sempre una sfida surreale nel ficcare
tutto quanto nelle valigie cercare di
[__] il sistema però in sostanza
Avevo troppa roba quindi che ho fatto
dato che ci avevo dei vestiti puliti
delle lenzuola pulite delle cose mi
aveva regalato la vecchia proprietà di
casa così eh le ho lasciate su una sedia
in aeroporto a Parigi perché nella mia
testa in questo modo se qualcuno aveva
bisogno le poteva prendere perché era
tutta roba pulita comunque utile
eccetera che succede mentre stavo
mangiando il gelato avevo superato i
controlli tutto quanto e stavo andando
per salire sull'aereo col mio girato in
mano vengo avvicinato da due energumeni
con un mitra che erano le guardie
dell'aeroporto mi fanno è lei questo
girano una videocamera e c'ero io che
mollare la roba
dico sì ci segua e arrivo nel punto in
cui ho lasciato la mia roba e scopro che
avevano ehm isolato un'area c'erano
tutti quanti c'era un perimetro di
persone tipo bomba con il fucile puntato
a me dicono cosa hai fatto cose cosa hai
lasciato là guarda sto vestiti mi metto
a ridere Ma sei pazzo Lo sai che periodo
siamo vai a prenderli io vado a
prenderli li sollevo mostro che sono
vestiti si avvicina un tizio con l'abito
da presidente Byblos con le Pinzone le
prende li butta in un Saccone così e mi
volevano fare una multa salatissima per
aver abbandonato di vestiti in aeroporto
[Musica]
è un bellissimo aneddoto aneddoto
Complimenti Rouge ti posso chiedere roba
di prendere un ultimo
scelgo al liceo e animali domestici
posso dire solo con un bellissimo socio
che si chiama fiamma e che la amo basta
al liceo ma perché questo Andai Non può
essere potrei partire da quando mi hanno
fatto la multa perché fumavano nei bagni
e per il nervoso ha dato un cazzotto e
mi sono rotta la mano ma è la cosa
peggiore era la mia estetica questo non
so se lo sa qualcuno di quelli che mi
seguono
non ci credo quando tu hai scattato
questa foto eri seria o no solo questo
ieri
te lo ricordi no mi hanno chiesto che
sta a fa io avevo risposto arcicci due
che sarebbe Cinecittà 2 era l'acronimo
coatto per di Cinecittà 2 e così si
chiude un ciclo Guglielmo dovevamo
arrivare fino a quello della tua
carriera nel senso
la mia famiglia inizia il primo ancora
no In cui vedo mia sorella e mia cugina
che vomitano incessantemente il giorno
successivo mio padre decide di pescare
del pesce e pulirlo sul ponte e poi
ovviamente dovendo pulire il ponte Tira
una secchiata d'acqua non accorgendosi
che la finestrella della camera mia di
mia sorella era aperta e così ci ha
inondato il letto di interiora di pesce
molto buono
il tender ha deciso bene di bucarsi e di
rompersi poi sempre il motore del Tender
mentre noi ce l'avevamo sopra a metà
strada tra la barca e la terraferma ti
posso dire che queste cose succedono in
continuazione quando fai viaggi in barca
e a me è successo di l'anno scorso ero
andato a fare monitoraggio di cetacei
col WWF è andato in tragedia Ma perché
è ripartito Bene sembrava una cosa da
influencer che sarà arricchito in
maniera sterile No il monitoraggio dei
cetacei col WWF dove devi fare vabbè Che
cos'è una merda Io pure faccio cagare
cioè incredibile
che non abbiamo visto un cazzo perché
per cinque giorni c'è stato un terremoto
tutti hanno sboccato e cagato in giro
stavo dicendo che cosa
cinque giorni abbiamo visto una Pinna
niente è un cazzo doveva esserci di
tutto lì invece c'è in maremoto ci
eravamo noi a rollare sulla barca e
tutti quanti che dopo due minuti dalla
partenza stavano sboccando queste date
il nostro viaggio Vabbè il mio singolo
su Spotify su iTunes bellissimo
bellissimo Ricordatevi che lui aveva
prestato la sua musica per il mio
spettacolo senza musica
tutte le ricerche di barbascura stanno
scritte lì ed è per questo che
concludiamo questa puntata de vita
puntata Ringraziando naturalmente
Antonino grazie
Ok nata oggi dalle ceneri di mille
Fenici Ragazzi grazie sempre per la
partecipazione noi ci vediamo con la
prossima puntata di vita buttata Ciao
[Musica]